mohammed al Zubaz berlin address is a
shipping container he fled Syria and has
been in the German capital for eight
months the 27 year old is on his own but
he's made some friends the qualified
electrical engineer says he wants to
build his future in Germany he's looking
for a job and says he's thinking of
additional training to improve his
chances
he's also been learning German for three
months this is Ophelia ina warning the
scan here I'm looking for an apartment
here I can't really study German here
very well because the room is very small
with two people in it it's very loud the
clients tomorrow on the Ziller but up to
now it doesn't really matter
bigger he lives in a migrant shelter
located on the outskirts of Berlin it's
capacity is about 370 people most of
them come from Syria Eritrea and the
Balkans people from 20 different
countries live here the bonnets company
set up the shelter it's one of four that
the container merchant has supplied in
Berlin in the last six months
it's made of 1,650 containers they come
from the Czech Republic Slovenia and
Slovakia the BOE needs company sells and
rents them they cost between 12,000 and
15,000 euros each for the small company
it's a huge Commission the likes of
which they've never had does the wooden
sets and star turnovers are growing up
of course it's powerful the costs are
multiplying to the investments I'm
having to make her many times larger
than what I can earn with the containers
when we use including all tea and cut so
it's not worth anything no it is you
invest in the future it's a growth pedra
bonus has taken out a 2 million euro
loan from the bank in order to finance
the operations
we saw no model weapon didn't yours
somebody knows he's outsourcing some of
the jobs to other companies assembly and
heating installation for example but now
he's got another problem
do you default site in the VIP container
factories have a delivery time of about
16 weeks at the moment so this one else
with locals for so we'll only get new
supplies just before Christmas what the
things we're already running out of
containers Germany is set to take in
800,000 migrants this year and can't
keep up with the influx people are being
put up in hotels and hostels to cover
the shortfall the business seems to be
paying off especially for the hostels
and hotels that don't have full
occupancy
the inflatable shelters produced by the
perronnette company are also in big
demand until about two years ago the air
domes were used primarily for gyms on
swimming pools but now para Nets chief
executive Juergen VEVRAA is prioritizing
other jobs he's received orders to put
up 20 new shelters in Germany in the
next six months I'm Frank Doyle in the
Wrigley Communion Belinda town states in
the federal government are all making
inquiries in time so are various foreign
governments this enormous need an answer
the numbers have surprised everyone the
towns are barely coping residents are
unhappy their gyms and sports facilities
are being used as shelters and that
limits them belong to the lighter one
and then there were just the sheer
number of arrivals make 3 monstrum
Leiden Jurgen Wolfram want tell us what
he's getting for rent but each air dome
is insured for 2 million euros the city
of Berlin is renting them a Berlin
charity for the homeless sets them up
and equips the emergency accomodation
about 300 people can stay in the 2,500
square meter area it's open plan so the
shelter can be ventilated but there are
50 sleeping compartments that fit a
maximum of 6 people each there's no fear
of a sanatorium is of course we have to
admit that it's profitable for us but on
the other hand we're not the ones who
created the migration emergency in
Germany instead the situation is just
developed and we're in a position to
help towns and cities handle the influx
of migrants things better than 15
thunderstorm en Gedi thordan the
migrants remain in the emergency
shelters for only about three or four
weeks the solution is just a temporary
one because of the heat and the noise in
the domes Jurgen VEVRAA says that his
tents will only be needed for a limited
time until enough migrant shelters are
built around the country